[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in frank isola he covers the
nba he's one of the stars of around the
horn and uh you can listen to the
starting lineup on uh siriusxm he's also
the uh net studio host on yes are you uh
and uh get off my lawn guy frank are you
that old that you're one of those guys
yes okay i thought you were
when men were men you were gonna say
when they would stay in it but dan isn't
it funny though all these teams now
all have you know performance coaches
the assistant performance coach and
everyone gets hurt more than they ever
did everyone plays less than they ever
did i don't know i i guess you could
hire me and i'll tell you
don't pitch or don't play this way you
won't get hurt i'm a medical genius
myself help me understand what's going
on with zion williamson that he's he's
been cleared to play five on five he's
in the layup line doing 360s
but he can't play in a game why yeah
well i don't know where the expression
came but if i have to hear the
expression ramp up or ramping up one
more time i can't take it anymore just
go out there and play you know he did
two things which for me were regrettable
one you know there's been a lot of talk
about his conditioning why he would ever
film a commercial drinking a mountain
dew sitting on his couch playing video
games is a little odd and now you're not
playing in games but you're doing 360
dunks i i is there part of him that
probably doesn't want to play because
he's in line to get a rookie contract
extension that could be part of it maybe
the pelicans are thinking at this point
are we really going to beat the phoenix
suns in the first round probably not so
what's the point they had originally
said if you remember he would be ready
for opening night yeah so here we are
that was in october
it's april he still isn't playing but i
just think it looks bad why work out
before the game and go through all this
stuff just do it after a shoot around do
your 360 dunks work out you should be
out there playing but he's not yeah i
don't understand it i can understand
trying to protect him but if that's i
can't imagine a doctor goes nope you're
not ready to play in the game but you
can go out there and do 360s that's okay
i don't understand that logic but do you
think zion is going to stay in new
orleans
i i would guess that he is i'd be
worried about paying him that much
because you know you look at the stat
how many games he's missed and to your
point about you know get off my lawn
you know you go back to michael jordan
his second year with the chicago bulls
remember he had a foot injury yeah i
brought that up
yeah they wanted him to shut it down and
remember in the last dance he talked
about going to chapel hill and he was
playing five on five he came back and
then they were load managing him he was
playing then missing a game and he
wanted to get into the playoffs he said
the heck with this my minutes are going
to go up i'm going to play they made the
playoffs and i think there is something
to be said for that playing in
competitive games that matter you know
the pelicans have wanted to get to this
point they want when they were in the
bubble they wanted to be in the play-in
tournament it didn't work out they're
here right now one win gets you a
playoff series against phoenix i think
there's some value in that but
apparently they don't do you think frank
vogel wanted to get fired
i think that he probably midway through
the season he was thinking you know what
if you're going to make the move how
about doing it right now the whole that
that whole thing was a mess and he was
easy to blame i still say they blame
trevorrisa first because remember he got
cut before they think the second or last
came to it really when trevor riza ben
frank vogel how about the comments by
russell westbrook i couldn't believe
that he said that where he brings up a
story about i left him a bottle of
champagne but i don't really know what
the issue was i don't know why he didn't
like me it's got nothing to do with you
personally you just weren't as good as
you once were and also you play it all
the time he would he played 77 78 games
he started every game i thought that was
unfair russell westbrook to say he had
an issue with me i don't think he had an
issue with you they were just trying to
figure out how you can best be effective
because you're just not as good as you
once were yeah i think he's delusional
and and he should take some blame there
when he said oh yeah i wasn't able to be
myself well you got more opportunities
than anybody on that roster to play
and you know is being yourself you know
missing jumpers i mean turnovers all of
those things and they probably are stuck
with him i'm get if if lebron likes
russell westbrook does he only like him
for one year or is he going to like him
for two years
yeah and the one thing that westbrook
has going for them i should say the
lakers have going for me does have an
expiring contract which could
potentially make him easier to trade i
know mark stein had a story out there
about potentially maybe the charlotte
hornets with gordon hayward's contract
we know that jordan and russell
westbrook do have a relationship so if
you're getting them on a you know just
for one year you could kind of make that
work but i i think for westbrook also
would probably frustrated him i think
all and this happens to a lot of guys
when they native new yorkers who play in
new york they all think it's going to be
a storybook type of hollywood ending and
a lot of times it doesn't work out like
that he goes to l.a it's the worst
experience of his career dan he's
getting booed for the first time he's
not playing well he's on one of the
worst teams that he's ever played for
and he took a lot of the blame which was
a little over the top as well because
we're going to criticize guys for not
playing at least russell westbrook
didn't bail out on the team and say i
got a sore knee i can't play in the
games but it just wasn't good enough and
the star players you want to hold him to
a high standard and he just didn't meet
that standard yeah i've always said that
about westbrook he plays hard
sometimes his mind and his body aren't
synced up and uh you know then then you
have some bad moments there also if you
look at this job how desirable coaching
the lakers is now with a.d
uh westbrook lebron going into season
20. you got to deal with the front
office here um
how enticing is this job are you going
to get top end people and would you at
least place a call to phil jackson
i'm sure genie bus already has i had
heard they're trying to get guys
on a two-year deal which kind of lines
up with lebron so maybe when lebron is
done they they would probably go in a
different direction there's only 30 of
those jobs it is the lakers but to your
point i looked it up today
you know they've only won over 37 games
three times in 10 years so it really has
been kind of a dysfunctional losing
situation the one outlier was the year
they went to the bubble and they won the
kind of summer league bubble
championship with lebron james otherwise
it really has it's been a poor
organization the last 10 years and
that's the thing you could blame as many
coaches as you want you also have to
look at the front office in ownership
and no offense to genie bus it really
hasn't worked out the last 10 years i
get it you did get the one championship
but for the most part it's been a losing
situation and there's been a lot of
dysfunction there yeah when you haven't
made the playoffs in seven of the last
nine years this isn't on frank vogel or
russell westbrook it's on something a
little bit larger more systemic we're
talking to frank isola he of course is
around the nets and uh you're the net
studio host um ben simmons any chance as
the nets
progress in the playoffs that he could
play
i guess i you know i don't know what can
you realistically expect from him and
the last time we saw him playing a game
that was june 20th
and that was you know
the last game of philadelphia couldn't
make free throws he was 15 of 45 from
the free-throw line in that series so
now after not playing with the
australian national team not playing any
preseason games regular season game
playing tournament game you might miss
games one and two of this series you're
just going to walk into a playoff series
in high pressure situations
is it going to be in the game in the
fourth quarter and what's going to
happen when you get when they're in the
penalty how if you're emayodok if it's
the celtics that he does play against
how do you not foul the guy send him to
the free throw line that's been a big
thing his confidence the last time we
saw him play his confidence was shot and
there was a story out there somewhere
where somebody said oh his confidence is
sky high how would we know that how are
you gauging that he hasn't played a
basketball game since last june 20th and
the last time we saw him play a he
wouldn't shoot and when he was at the
free-throw line he couldn't make a free
throw and i wonder about this that in
other sports you know baseball you've
had guys who can't throw the ball back
to the pitcher
you've had pitchers who can't throw the
ball over the plate you have steve sax
or chuck knobloch who can't throw it
from second to first
you know we look at that and we go okay
golfers uh kevin nogg would get at the
top of his swing and he didn't know how
to get back down to the ball
uh yips you know guys who were putting
now
you know we don't factor that in with
basketball players that they get to the
free throw line
and they have they freeze up they don't
know how to do something
it feels like that's been left
unexplored whereas we've seen a lot more
instances or at least we've unearthed
those in golf and baseball why is that
no i i think that's a great call and i
also think how many times have we've
seen guys they'll show them in warm-ups
or they'll show them on the practice
court and they're knocking down free
throws giannis was like that if you
remember
last year and then of course he figured
his whole situation out during the
playoffs which was pretty extraordinary
the way that he did that but i think
that's a very fair point i think maybe
you feel isolated out there at the free
throw line and to your point you kind of
get the yips and you cannot make free
throws and you know shaq was a guy that
was a poor free throw shoot i remember
the day that he got when it was
announced he was going to the hall of
fame and they asked him about free throw
shooting and about shooting underhand he
said i'd rather miss all of them than
shoot him underhand but he also used to
bring up the point he they didn't really
lose big games
because he missed free throws but you
could kind of relate a lot of the free
throws that ben simmons missed last year
against atlanta to them blowing that
game you know game five where they had
the big lead and then obviously game
seven when they had a big lead mason
plumley is right-handed
he's shooting free throws left-handed if
you go from right-handed to left-handed
frank go all the way to underhand
i agree right you have a better chance
of making underhand free throws
and you can't say well i don't want to
be embarrassed no you're already
embarrassed you make less than 40 of
your free throws
yeah well what you need to do is why
don't you get rick barry on and all you
have to do is ask him about it and then
sit back and he'll go on for about 15 20
minutes and he's going to tell you how
he would sell it i know he's going to
solve everything i mean rick barry is a
piece of work you know how long he'll go
on for but there is something to be said
for that and it's also a vanity thing i
don't want to be the guy that everyone's
making fun of shooting free throws but
yet nobody makes fun of you if you make
them frank
i agree i don't i don't get it and it's
a big and you're losing games because of
it that that's the thing that gets you
uh i was surprised with the nets and the
cavaliers that you had a
near perfect game by kyrie and a
unbelievable game with durant but you
had to hold on against the cavaliers at
home
um
how does that bode for them playing
against the celtics yeah and the big
thing with steve nash and steve nash
two-time nvp great offensive player when
he played for phoenix all everybody
talked about was offense never defense
all steve talks about with the nets is
defense how they need to get better one
of their last games of the season they
played the houston rockets they gave up
a ton of points their final game against
indiana where you would have needed you
know a scorebook to figure out who these
guys were they put up 126 on the
brooklyn nets defense is an issue with
them now cleveland did cuddle i think it
was either five or six it was never one
possession game of the final three
quarters but they had a 22 point lead
and cleveland got back into it it's an
issue and if cleveland had had jared
allen that could have been a much
different story then that's very easy it
could be playing tomorrow night just to
get into the plays offensively there's
nothing to worry about with the nets
kevin durant is at a different level he
makes the right play every single time
both he and kyrie were double-digit
assists they could buy for 23 assists in
that game you don't have to worry about
that team offensively the big thing is
going to be defense which we were just
talking about ben simmons offensively he
would help them defensively great to
talk to you as always thank you frank
good seeing you dan take care that's
frank isola
uh commissioner silver will be on the
program tomorrow you know i got a
question for the commissioner tomorrow i
would hope well no i got one question
that nobody is thinking about right now
you know what let me ask i'll keep but
let me bring back frank here frank i
have one i have one question here for uh
the commission i got a few questions
about you know load management but i'm
going to ask you you play the role of uh
commissioner silver
good
why is it we allow players to carry the
ball
is is there an infraction of carrying
the ball
can that be called in today's nba why do
we allow that when you know iverson and
stockton you know we would call carrying
on them
and i think early in the season it does
get called and then it seems like as the
season goes on they call it less and
less and every once in a while out of
nowhere it comes out ask him this what
if we changed if to win postseason
awards you had to play in a minimum
amount of games
whether it's 68 or 70 and how about this
too scoring title all that stuff make it
total no one talks about who led the nfl
in average touchdown passes per game
it's total so trey young led the league
in total
points total assist maybe guys on a
second out of a back-to-back would just
play the second half it's not going to
affect your average but it'll help your
totals let's go to total since guys are
playing high 50s low 60s well also you
you could put a minimum to make the
first and second and third team all nba
and money factors into that now with all
nba so make it i i agree put put that on
there so incentivize the players to play
in more of the game and also no
positions give me the five best players
on first team five best players five
best players rudy gobert good player
not one of the top 15 players in the nba
yeah and then you know they they benefit
you know how many great centers have
there been now maybe a few more now but
um i i just think five best players i
might be five guards but they're five
best players and and remember when that
first came up and a bunch of the center
said well that's not fair because now
nobody's going to vote a center well the
top the guys that are probably going to
finish one two and three in the mvp vote
this year are embiid nicole jokic
giannis and tedecumbo yeah all big men
giannis more of a 4-5 but to your point
you know they're going to be some years
where the f the five best players are
guards some years where they're small
forwards this year three of the best
players in the league are all big men
thank you frank and thanks for playing
the role of commissioner commissioner